one bit that i was gonna ask you about
that i i thought maybe i disagreed with
was you talk like the title of the book
is think big yeah and the vibe i got
from the chapter around goals is that
you're keen on people setting
or
perhaps not but like what one camp of
people in the sphere is encouraging
people to set these big hairy audacious
goals
and then figuring out the small steps
taken you can you can take to get there
but then there's another camp and this
is sort of where
where i think i am whereby i think
in a way i feel maybe setting goals is a
bit overrated because if you're setting
a goal then
you're
essentially to me that feels like a
contract to be unhappy until you hit the
goal and then you hit the goal and then
you have this like fleeting sense of
like oh i hit a million subscribers cool
yeah
you know my day to day hasn't really
changed et cetera et cetera so the way i
kind of think about goals is i try and
throw goals out the window and instead
just focus on those like what do i
actually want to do but i don't know if
i'm just like bsing myself and like
you're doing okay so
that seems to be working for you i mean
i think so so for people who read the
book the goal is really there to serve
two purposes so one so that you start
investing in your career so it helps to
find the tasks this week
and two so that you actually bring your
future self forward so you're not always
investing in activities that just serve
you in the present day but in the book i
do talk about the idea that every um
sunday so every kind of well i i pick
sundays it's the start of my week that
you reflect on how the week previous
went and you look to see whether or not
there are new opportunities that you
should be pivoting your goal for so i
see the think big part of the book as
really giving people a direction so they
can set off on a journey and they start
walking and more interesting things
might actually come along but they make
a conscious decision to follow those
interesting things so then they go off
on a slightly different journey so
if you take your own career for example
it was probably a great idea that you
studied medicine and cambridge right and
now you have an entirely different
career but you are using some of the
skills that you actually learned in the
university so in that particular case
you would have sat back and said
actually do i really want to pivot and
do a large pivot and the answer would
have been yes but had you never gone
into medici
medical school maybe you would never
have started walking in this direction
and come to the destination so it's
really about movement oh okay that's
really interesting um i was having these
thoughts i was it was a few weeks ago
and i was on a date and we went we were
kind of driving around afterwards just
like chatting and i was kind of thinking
that like driving around without a
destination it's just like if it felt a
bit wrong and so i just put the
destination of the like the mcdonald's
drive through in the sat nav and it
wasn't really about the destination it
was about okay i've got a destination
now
now i know what what the journey is
and when we got to the mcdonald's
drivers was like what else it's
mcdonald's drive through like that the
destination is actually not that
important but the point is i was
thinking huh maybe having the
destination
lets you kind of set the direction for
your journey and then you can always
change your mind as you as you go
further down the line and as humans we
love certainty so even if we've created
for ourselves this is the goal that
we're moving towards then we change our
mind for the period of time that we're
moving there is certainty one of the
biggest things that hampers people's
growth and you know stops them kind of
getting to the place where they probably
deserve to be
is that they feel that the journey is
actually uncertain so by kind of having
that destination allows you to kind of
to move towards it oh okay yeah this
reminds me of advice i got when i was in
in med school where like once you once
you've done your once you start your
clinical years the question everyone
asks is oh what specialty do you want to
do and the honest answer for the vast
majority of people is i don't freaking
out i have no idea like you know there
are those odd like weirdos that i've
decided on the age at the age of three
they want to be a neurosurgeon yeah um
but for most of us it's like honestly i
don't know i just want to kind of get a
feel of different specialties and kind
of
um and the advice that one of one of the
consultants who i really respected gave
me was that like honestly just pick
something and start moving towards it
because then you will start doing things
that will build up your cv and you'll
start actually finding opportunities
your way and then if you want to change
your mind it's much easier to change
direction when you're moving forward
rather than when you when you're
stationary and you learn about yourself
as well what do i like and what do i
what do i dislike which you won't do if
you're just if you're still kind of
standing still so kind of you know did i
write about what should you do if you
have no idea what you want to do in the
future where a lot of young people are
and actually people who you know and who
are later in life and again it's really
about thinking what do i kind of like
doing now so let's do some more of that
and move towards a goal and then on the
way being really reflective am i
enjoying these tasks or am i just doing
it because i like the idea of becoming a
surgeon or becoming a lawyer or becoming
another job title and i really want
people to move away from the second you
know i kind of think with the future of
work
we have this disruption where people who
are able to
kind of pivot know what their skills are
job craft which you might which you've
mentioned already it would really stand
to them
um
yeah so it's like you're moving away
from being and more towards doing yes
being a doctor versus like what does the
day-to-day of practicing medicine
actually look like and does this sound
like the sort of thing that is my idea
of fun right now and i guess
i guess like it's it's kind of you know
there's that thing in in the research
about it's it's hard for us to predict
what will make us happy in the future
yeah but it's a reasonable first
approximation that the sort of stuff i
enjoy doing now like talking to people
like you or like making videos is likely
to also probably make me happy in the
future and if it doesn't then well i can
just change course yeah this is like a
great search so what what you know what
the government should have done in
covert and some governments incredibly
well was what we call this grid search
strategy where they get new data they
update their decision making based on
the data and they're willing to go
backwards or they're willing to go left
and they're willing to go right and
always having that openness to a change
of direction and i think if we kind of
bring that into careers that you know
really we don't know our preferences
very well we've watched some tv when
we're young so depending on what you
watch that might actually ultimately
determine your career maybe you move
towards that if you have no idea but
always paying attention to am i enjoying
the tasks is it do i feel purpose if i
was doing this in five years time would
i be really really happy um you know my
director in the lsd manuscript she spoke
to me kind of about careers and kind of
really thinking five years ahead of time
what's your next challenge going to be
because by the time five years comes
you're not going to be able to do that
challenge unless you've spent a decent
amount of time doing activities that
makes you credible to be that person
standing in that room and really taking
that approach i think can help people